[Music]
on this Friday night Canada's Growing
Pains as our population Rises so too is
the unemployment rate we almost need 25
to 35 000 jobs each and every month why
some blame the Bank of Canada terrible
track record we built a lemon we cut
Corners the endless problems plaguing
ottawa's LRT system one of Putin's
fiercest critics hit with a harsh
sentence Alexi navalny's message to the
Russian public and four-legged fire
prevention they've been doing it for a
million years the critical help these
herds of animals provide
global national with Farah Nasser
reporting tonight Chris gayles good
evening and thanks very much for joining
us we begin with a pretty bleak outlook
for Canada's Workforce for the third
consecutive month the unemployment rate
Rose data from statistics Canada shows
in July it ticked up slightly to 5.5
percent of 0.1 percent increase over the
previous month but that still translates
to more than 1.1 million unemployed
people across the country it's also a
noticeable difference from the historic
lows around the same time last year as
micro League shows us in our top story
tonight it's another sign Canada's
troubled economy is struggling to keep
up with a booming population
the Canadian economy has to start
digging up some new jobs
that's the message coming in loud and
clear from statistics Canada which
pointed to the construction industry as
the major culprit when it comes to job
losses a deeper dive into the numbers
suggests the economy is at a Crossroads
it starts with population growth which
has risen more sharply in recent years
largely due to immigration But Rising
unemployment numbers particularly of
late suggest the economy isn't creating
enough jobs to absorb the larger
Workforce as recently as a year ago you
know we were looking at a million vacant
jobs we were looking at you know all
kinds of different Industries staring
down the the face of shortages that's
that I don't think that's the concern
anymore you know I actually think it's
tipping the other way other complicating
factors to consider a five percent rise
in hourly wages over the past year could
push inflation up which runs counter to
everything the Bank of Canada is trying
to accomplish with its rate hikes and
those higher interest rates make it more
expensive for businesses to borrow money
and that in turn leads to job losses
it's a catch-22 basically it involves
making a trade-off like how much how
much unemployment can we tolerate to
keep inflation alone it sounds like
we're going to find out because most
economists see the Bank of Canada
holding steady on interest rates until
inflation is well under control
I think that by the time we get into the
first half of next year uh inflation
will very likely be at the two percent
level and they can start to think about
normalizing because one thing that you
have to always keep in mind with the
Bank of Canada is even though their
target is two percent inflation they're
very worried about the risks of over
tightening they don't want to cause a
recession so we need more jobs yet the
drive to lower inflation is keeping the
economy from creating them all of which
adds to the ongoing post-pandemic
hangover microlay Global News Toronto
the Russian economy is also Under
Pressure the ruble dropped to a 17-month
low today the decline to 95 rubles
against the U.S dollar is the lowest
since the first month of Russia's
full-scale invasion of Ukraine now
Ukraine is claiming a significant gain
in that war it launched a drone attack
badly damaging a warship at a major
Russian port a Ukrainian intelligence
official released this grainy drone
video shot at the Black Sea Naval Base
it's about 110 kilometers east of Crimea
and the port is key for exports the hit
marks the first time a commercial
Russian Port has been targeted in the
war the damaged chip was tugged to shore
today leaking oil and listing heavily
the Black Sea has become an important
Battleground since Russia pulled out of
a grain deal two weeks ago
Kremlin critic Alexi navalny got 19
years tacked on to the nine-year
sentence he's already serving a Russian
Court convicted the opposition activist
of extremism navalny has always claimed
the charges against him are politically
motivated and as Mike Armstrong reports
he's urging Russians not to lose the
will to resist the government
reporters turned up at the gates of
penal colony number six knowing they
wouldn't be allowed in they were there
they said to at least be nearby for
moral support
this supporter expected a sentence
likely he said as harsh as possible
now navalny himself a day before this
appearance predicted what he called a
stalinist sentence something strong
enough to frighten Russians and keep
them from resisting the government
navalny said he expected 18 years it was
in fact even longer 19. this for a man
already serving nine and a half years
after the hearing navalny posted to
social media through supporters saying
the number of years didn't matter but he
won't be released as long as the current
regime is in power but he says the
sentence is for the Russian public quote
it is for you you not me are being
frightened and deprived of the will to
resist you are being forced to surrender
your country of Russia without a fight
to the gang of traitors thieves and
Scoundrels who have seized power this
enormous term
um has only one goal to scare as much
people as possible
charismatic navalny has been the most
popular opposition figure since Vladimir
Putin took power he rose to prominence
originally as a blogger exposing
corruption and went on to lead major
anti-kremlin protests
after a nearly fatal poisoning in 2020
while in Russia he was moved to and
treated in Germany I've only then chose
to return in January the next year and
has been detained ever since the latest
sentence was for running an extremist
operation from prison the government
appears to be stepping up its Crackdown
on descent with a Russian presidential
election set for March of next year the
regime is perhaps aware that it may be
going into that election without a
victory in Ukraine now Friday's sentence
also means navalny will be moved to
another stricter facility supporters say
that will be to limit access and make it
harder for his voice to be heard Mike
Armstrong Global News
the war in Ukraine and increased
military maneuvering by China appears to
be putting Canada's own military
Readiness front and center and Canadians
want Ottawa to do more a poll conducted
exclusively for Global News looks at
Canadians defense priorities and the
areas they're most concerned about
protecting here at home David Baxter
reports the
foreign the Canadian Armed Forces are in
a transformative period and for most
Canadians change can't come soon enough
new polling from ipsos done exclusively
for Global News finds that more than
half of Canadians find the calf is quote
old and Antiquated but there's a way to
fix that the solution to that Canadians
tell us is probably giving them more
money and if they could just find their
way through the what Canadian sea is
incompetence and political interference
they feel that Canadians feel that they
could get there 56 percent of people
surveyed by ipso shared that old and
Antiquated view that characterization
emerged and focus groups the CAF ran
last year along with a perception it is
underfunded this lines up with ipsos
findings 75 percent of Canadians think
funding should increase to help
Safeguard National sovereignty and our
territory 7 out of 10 Canadians are
concerned about Canada's ability to
defend itself
up
the pool found that is being driven by
Russia's invasion of Ukraine and China's
movements in the Taiwan Strait including
a close call with the U.S warship
earlier in the spring deterrence is much
cheaper than going to war and I think
that's the point that has to be made to
a lot of Canadians is that while uh we
can rest on our Laurels and perhaps lean
on the United States they're not going
to put up with it for much longer the
Arctic is where most Canadians worry
about territorial security according to
the poll with 73 percent wanting more
bases in the far north the thing that
probably is driving their biggest level
of concern is our Northern neighbor
which is which is Russia and what's
going on in Ukraine right now and some
of those old Coral War feelings towards
Russia and the north are probably coming
back up in this year's budget the
government tout 6.1 billion dollars over
the next five years to shore up
Continental defense and unveil defense
policy update later this year it's
something that will be closely watched
by Ally it's like the Americans with
their new NORAD Commander promising to
have tough conversations with Canada on
defense spending Chris
all right thanks David well it's still a
waiting game for residents forced out of
their homes in southern BC as a raging
Wildfire Burns near the village of Chase
a sudden shift in winds earlier this
week saw the Adams Lake Fire raced
towards homes and cabins forcing
evacuation orders despite the threat no
properties have been lost to the fire so
far which has grown to about 2500
hectares above average temperatures are
expected in the BC interior this weekend
but will cool down by Monday bringing
some much needed relief
with high temperatures fueling wildfires
across much of the globe how more
countries are turning to grazing animals
for help that's coming up later in the
newscast right now though blistering
temperatures aren't just affecting land
the planets oceans are warming at an
alarming rate hitting a new record high
this week the average global ocean
surface temperature hit 20.96 degrees
Celsius at the end of July according to
the Copernicus climate modeling service
that beats the previous record of 20.95
degrees set in 2016. scientists say
temperatures are being driven by El Nino
and overall climate change oceans are a
key climate regulator they soak up heat
produce oxygen and drive weather changes
well it's become the butt of jokes in
the nation's capital coming up
ottawa's non-stop trouble with its train
system plus the third tornado to hit the
same city in the same summer the cleanup
underway right now and fans of Breaking
Bad and Better Call Saul mourn the death
of a popular actor
[Music]
cleanup is underway in a neighborhood
south of downtown
Ottawa after a tornado touched down
during a severe thunderstorm yesterday
evening trees were operated with many
crashing into homes
Ottawa fire Services says part of a roof
was ripped off a house at another
property fencing and a pool house were
destroyed with a nearby garden shed left
standing the storm also brought hail the
size of ping-pong balls power in the
area was knocked out for a time but
thankfully no one was hurt
people living in Ottawa are suffering
with major problems on its Light Rail
train system nearly three weeks ago the
capital's Confederation Line ground to a
halt after a recent inspection found an
increased risk of derailment as
Mackenzie gray reports it's just the
latest in a flood of issues that have
infuriated Ottawa commuters since the
line first opened in 2019.
nearly four years after it opened every
single train of ottawa's newest Light
Rail line is in the shop being checked
for a defect that could cause a
derailment we are all disappointed that
we do not have a solution that will
allow us to safely restore service it's
been nearly three weeks since the system
was shut down due to the same problem
that sent this train off the tracks in
August of 2021
it's just one of a myriad of issues
plaguing the Confederation Line just
weeks after it opened the train doors
jammed those trains purpose built for
ottawa's climate but cold weather hot
weather and freezing rain have all
shuddered the system multiple times it's
not just all Mother Nature's fault the
city admitting the Train's Wheels aren't
perfectly round the track itself could
also be the problem but as of now the
core issue hasn't been found it's also a
surprise to me why why it takes so long
to identify the problem the trains being
closed aren't the only issue at many of
the underground stations there's
significant water damage but here at
Parliament station there's a unique
issue it smells like crap during
construction a sewer line was punctured
leading the city to discreetly put up
air fresheners which didn't solve the
problem that pattern of secrecy revealed
extensively in a public inquiry which
laid major fault at former mayor Jim
Watson and other senior City staff all
of whom secretly communicated about
construction issues over WhatsApp I have
concluded that the people of Ottawa
deserve better
with the entire train system closed OC
Transpo has brought back the buses the
LRT was supposed to replace two weeks
ago a 26 year old woman died when she
was hit by one of them
former paralympian Sally Thomas relies
on OC Transpo to get around we built a
lemon we cut Corners too many secrets
were were held back from the public
and they rushed things Thomas moved from
Belleville Ontario to Ottawa
specifically for a proper transit system
would you still have moved to Ottawa
knowing the transit troubles I would
definitely go somewhere else OC
transpose says the 2.1 billion dollar
Light Rail will reopen August 14th
despite the closure there has been at
least one Ottawa occupant that's been
able to ride the rails no word on if he
paid for his ticket
Mackenzie gray Global News
Ottawa
Celine Dion's sister has revealed the
singer is really struggling with her
health and unlikely to return to
performing anytime soon Dion was
diagnosed with stiff person syndrome
last December and in a report from Le
Journal de Montreal Dion's sister
Claudette reveals doctors are struggling
to find medication that works for her
she also reveals Dion's other sister
Linda has moved in with Celine to help
care for her Dion's upcoming World Tour
has been canceled
and some sad news for fans of the
award-winning series Breaking Bad and
it's acclaimed spin-off Better Call Saul
Mark Margolis the actor widely known for
his unnerving bell ringing as Hector
Salamanca died on Thursday following a
short illness Margolis earned an Emmy
nomination for his portrayal of the
feared drug cartel enforcer he was also
known for his supporting roles in
memorable films like Scarface and
Requiem for a Dream Margolis was 83
years old
[Music]
just ahead armed conflict triggers a
humanitarian crisis in Sudan
[Music]
in West Africa the military Junta that
seized control of Niger is trying to cut
the country's ties with France the Junta
says it's now revoked the former French
colonies military cooperation agreements
with France deals that have allowed over
a thousand French troops into Niger to
help fight Islamic insurgents French
officials say they only recognize
decisions from the legitimate government
International allies have been calling
for president Muhammad bazoom's
reinstatement after he was arrested in
last week's coup the economic community
of West African States has given niger's
coup leaders until Sunday to step down
and release by Zoom there are reportedly
plans for potential military
intervention if that deadline is missed
and three months after fighting erupted
between Sudan's armed forces and a
paramilitary group there both sides are
being accused of committing atrocities
that could amount to war crimes and
crimes against humanity more than 3
million people have been displaced since
the deadly power struggle began in April
many have fled to neighboring countries
to escape the Bloodshed intensifying A
desperate Refugee crisis Redmond Shannon
reports but first a warning some of the
images in this story are disturbing
it could be argued these are some of the
luckier victims of Sudan's conflict
drenched displaced desperate but alive
hundreds of thousands of people have
fled into Chad and South Sudan during
the Region's rainy season
Islam trudges to What's Left of her tent
shelter people here have lost their
three or four loved ones and came here
with nothing to eat or drink people are
arriving the way they have fled with
very little on them and so totally
dependent on humanitarian assistance to
survive along these border locations
there's a very remote places with very
limited infrastructure those suffering
the most are those who understand the
least these children treated from
malnutrition at a Chad border Hospital
in May more than 50 babies reportedly
died of starvation and fever after an
orphanage was cut off by the fighting
between the Army and the paramilitary
rapid support force or rsf
estimates on the number of Civilian
deaths range from 1100 to many thousands
more likely the latter
the international criminal court is
investigating allegations of war crimes
and crimes against humanity in the
western Darfur region with reports of
looting's killings and gang rapes the
conflict has encouraged ethnic violence
to flare up again there a grim echo of
the Darfur genocide 20 years ago the
longer this conflict takes the more it
will take on an ethnic Dimension
um as both sides try and recruit for
their cause and we will also see much
more of a civil war scenario as the
state collapse continues to take place
the conflict is little more than a power
grab between the leaders of each side
dressed up as a righteous fight for
Sudan but destroying it in the process
Redmond Shannon Global News London
Nature's firefighters coming up next why
more countries are turning to animals to
help keep wildfires under control
[Music]
around the globe extremely hot weather
is fueling aggressive wildfires and
climatologists warn the fires will only
grow in frequency and intensity but
there might be a secret weapon in
communities willing to think outside the
box Jamie Maraca reports
William Simpson lives alongside more
than 100 Wild Horses a herd he credits
for saving his home in rural California
in 2018 as firefighters battled a 16-day
blaze closing in on his property
they use these natural fire breaks
created by the horses to get Toe to Toe
with the fire and they stopped it the
grass where the horses had grazed gave
firefighters an edge leaving little for
the Flames to feed on
it's a mitigation method currently being
tested in Spain and Portugal where
wildfires erupted amid a brutal summer
heat wave they're a small group of
horses and bison have been reintroduced
and in Canada since 2018 a herd of goats
has come back year over year to help
clear land for firefighters in
Lethbridge Alberta so instead of a six
foot flan you might have a six inch
flame so it's just safer it's easier to
fight there is science behind the idea
researchers found as humans began to
dominate the extinction of large or Mega
herbivores correlated to an increase in
fire activity but using modern day
mammals as mowers experts warn may only
help in specific situations there are
places where grass fuels are what fuel
fire and there are places where it's
Woody fuels that fuel fire and if you
have an herbivore that eats grass
they're not really going to help reduce
fire in a system where the fuel is not
grass exactly how the addition of more
herbivores would affect the ecosystem is
still up for debate for Simpson the
value these Wild Horses bring is obvious
yes now his focus is to rewild and
relocate them to areas where they would
Thrive and benefit the land while
maintaining the brush these horses do
that naturally they've been doing it for
a million years we need to let them go
do their job determined to protect the
herd that helps protect his home
Jamie moroccer Global News
and that is global national for this
Friday night I'm Chris gayles tonight's
your candidate is Banff National Park in
Alberta thanks very much for watching
calling Christy is going to be at the
anchor desk tomorrow hope you have a
great night and an even greater weekend
[Music]
thank you